[Música]
empezamos una de mis secciones favoritas
en directo américa la revista de prensa
con rosa pérez más de euros a bienvenida
feliz viernes ya llegamos al fin de
semana y comenzamos con el carbón brief
de reino unido- análisis que países son
históricamente los responsables del
cambio climático que tanto nos ha
afectado últimamente rosa buenos días a
golpes exactamente hemos querido ver
cómo este medio especializado prepara un
poco el terreno de cara a la cob 26 que
recordemos se va a celebrar en noviembre
entonces precisamente uno de los puntos
que está sobre la mesa es el aumento de
la temperatura global y este medio se
fija en como cada país del mundo ha
participado en esto en el aumento de la
temperatura global desde
1850 y porque este año porque recordemos
que en los acuerdos de parís fue también
el año que se estableció como punto de
referencia previo a la industrialización
entonces precisamente este artículo
defiende que tiene que haber una
justicia climática y que los países que
más han participado en las emisiones de
co2 a la atmósfera también son los que
deben actuar de una forma más
contundente entonces vemos este que
consta en este artículo donde pues está
el ranking y vemos en qué medida las
emisiones provienen de la combustión de
combustibles fósiles o de la actividad
ligada a la explotación de la tierra
como es la deforestación y vemos bien en
eeuu en primer lugar china que alcanzó
el segundo lugar en 2007 donde antes se
encontraba rusia que ahora está en
tercer lugar luego vemos brasil
indonesia sobre todo por actividades
ligados esto a la deforestación y a
luego encontramos pues alemania india el
reino unido japón y también lo que nos
dice este artículo es que si el
transporte mundial en transporte
internacional marítimo aéreo fuera
considerado como un país ocuparía el
décimo lugar en términos de emisiones y
déjame solo destacar una cosita más raúl
y es que evidentemente este orden cambia
si tenemos en cuenta la población de
cada país y lo que serían las emisiones
per cápita entonces se situaría en
primer lugar nueva zelanda seguido de
canadá y en último y en tercer lugar
perdón a australia rosa terrible no está
lista el daño que estamos haciendo
nuestro planeta continuamos también
hablando de cambio climático vamos a
francia el mediapad activismo climático
la criminalización se intensifica porque
dice que el minimización a qué se
refiere pues raúl se refiere a un juicio
que tuvo lugar precisamente ayer en que
se juzgaban siete activistas en defensa
del clima que participaron de una acción
el 3 de octubre de 2020 el año pasado en
que pues luchaban contra la ampliación
del aeropuerto de parís al de gol que es
el mayor aeropuerto de francia y que
pretendía para 2037 aumentar su tráfico
de pasajeros en un 50 por ciento
entonces en una acción en contra de esta
ampliación ocuparon la plataforma de la
terminal y pues fueron desalojados por
la policía e interpelados etcétera y
ayer es el celebró el juicio en que la
fiscalía pide entre otras cosas entre 1
y 3 meses de prisión condicional y en la
crónica del juicio este medio destaca
como los activistas defendieron que
están las vías de protesta prácticamente
agotadas que hay que actuar pues
para contra el cambio climático y que es
una obligación con las generaciones
presentes y futuras así es rosa
cambiamos ahora información dejamos a un
lado el cambio climático para hablar de
facebook que también ha sido uno de los
temas grandes de esta semana vamos al
país en españa que dice facebook es
demasiado grande y sí que lo es es raúl
pues el país en su editorial se suma a
estas demandas de regulación de los
gigantes tecnológicos la editorial no se
centra solamente en facebook sino que
alcanza digamos pide la regulación de lo
que se llaman gafas o gafas según quién
y por este en estas siglas encontramos
pues google apple facebook y amazon y
hay quien incluye también microsoft y
pues este artículo defiende no como
estas grandes empresas digamos que
arbitran lo que es el espacio digital en
internet y en tanto que nuestras vidas
en la mayor parte del mundo ya son
prácticamente desvincule able index
vinculables de de estas grandes
plataformas en que tenemos todos pues un
alter ego digital precisamente pues las
consecuencias de las decisiones que
toman estas grandes empresas pues nos
afectan
inevitablemente a nuestro día a día y
pide pues el país que se acabe con el
monopolio de facebook algo que como
hemos venido comentando es también la
intención de la autoridad competente en
eeuu el gran monopolio digital rosa
seguimos también hablando de facebook y
una revista que me encantan sus portadas
la revista 'time' delete facebook borrar
facebook es esa portada rosa eso es el
raúl pues las portadas de la revista
'time' a menudo son muy comentadas por
todos los medios de comunicación también
y bueno es que la portada lo dice todo
no borrar facebook
borrar o cancelar y en eso estamos un
poco todos no porque recordemos que
cuando hubo este apagón esta caída el
lunes prácticamente la mitad de la
humanidad se vio afectada 3500 millones
de usuarios raúl es que el poder no que
tiene esta plataforma sobre nuestras
vidas es incalculable y recordemos que
no es la primera vez que mark zuckerberg
está en la portada de la revista 'time'
sino que en el año 2010 fue elegido
persona del año que es una clasificación
que hace esta revista práctica desde
hace 100 años eso sí empezó con hombre
del año allí en el año 1927 y a finales
de los 80 lo cambió por persona del año
y en 2010 pues es el fundador de
facebook fue elegido y bueno vemos esta
semana que las declaraciones de
francisco ven el apagón pues ha llevado
a toda esta polémica y este
cuestionamiento acerca de su poder como
vidrios y apagón rosa no el efecto tanto
oh sí pues yo creo que pues por suerte
no dependían de estas plataformas a
nivel económico o personal a nivel
urgente el lunes pasado y fue como un
momento como de paréntesis de
desconexión pero reconozco que es verdad
que hemos basado tanto en nuestro día a
día en estas plataformas de forma
consciente o inconsciente que mucha
gente pues se vio muy afectada incluso
para trabajo rosa muchísimas gracias
feliz fin de semana nos vemos el lunes
con más titulares de la prensa
internacional vamos ahora con nuestro
primer invitado el día
[Música]